[Music]
the title of Grand Master was first
officially awarded in 1950 now in 2017
at the st. Louis winter Invitational
that tradition continues hello chess
fans and welcome to day four of the 2017
winter invitational the GM and IM norm
tournament today we see round six and
seven and this is the last day that we
will have two rounds played in just one
day recently we started seeing the
players get mathematically eliminated
and the numbers of possible norm earners
are dwindling stick with us on YouTube
for the next couple of days as we wind
the tournament down to its thrilling
conclusion we've seen some of the
hopefuls here in the GM norm section but
here's one of the gatekeepers
representing hungry Grandmaster David
Burgess David you played Nikhil Kumar
today and you completed what you called
the trifecta and I'd like you to show us
some of that game if you will so I faked
minute before I want to change this
screen it's going do six I really wanted
to get rid of the Queen unfortunately I
was not able to and here for instance
she could have a clean g4 maybe it's a
proxy server but it's very suspicious
I'm not sure vertical green 84 and the
different tribes oh yeah i'm not sure
what he says Luke c7 which enable need
to play f5 the point is this a fire is
not hanging because pretty check me on
that face so he left the back rank so I
try to catalyze capitalize on that okay
now i'm talking with these six I place
exhibition is supreme in the spot replay
King JJ this is real logical and again
the point is if I play Queen these six
he always has its Queen c8 and now my
phone is on c4
hanging and I'm not sure it looks very
good i have to pause but how to make
progress you know this was my main
problem here so i had to retreat I
pitches 33 is nothing much but I had to
put back be to creating some potential
pressure on this diagram obvious that's
my main objective to play some e 6 and
opening lines and everything okay we
shall be too and if it should be seven
and I already like it to me like two
three minutes left here training tire or
something I wasn't sure when doing here
so I say this is just need changing at
the force matters here hope hoping that
that is don't check me if you know so
fjc six animals fa c 6-r Queen DA's and
I a look at fun that's a strong move and
I think I'm still winning even though
this pawn structure is now a delish
messed up compared to what I had I have
doubled pawns but the point is that you
cannot move you can never take on d5
because I just capturing either punk and
I one structure is just perfect and if
you place Bischoff c8 i also have
sometimes you have seven more so and
maybe two or community three look at
seven or first women or vocus i
immediately and g standpoint were really
a huge story from and very special i
paid a stick pretty logical and i think
probably the trickiest move ever I made
here so I played here Queen d2 a me to
take a nice chicks right and trying to
regroup America I basically refers to my
queen here this side they're not doing
much on before so and he after community
to I really i need i saw this checkmate
and i made my opponent believe that i've
landed upon this was i started i started
shaking my head oh I got how to have a
nervous and he got close like this
took and you know I was like oh yeah
I've done that his hat ok there is this
tree which I mean nothing I ok did
indeed I didn't do it obviously but just
from standing on psychology yeah it's
sometimes worse but probably ok he took
a nice to each other lose you know start
so probably only move skin gate seven
but I was going to play Queen communi
for and i believe is totally lost for
like so i thought because now it has a
mixed we know five check the idea if it
goes skiing age 8 and quincy sticks and
you cannot take 3g5 because the CSUN
rookies hanging and if you again if you
take edge recaptured either pawn and
black camry we'll first back 27 then
just check on at five if you say g6 now
age of 25 and my two accounts are seven
just deadly you know the diagonal is
ready for bed so if you breaking g8 now
just queen g6 and again let's a look at
fades probably just look at seven
meaning immediately so yeah this is just
a killer here I don't know probably lost
anyways but this was just really a nice
way to finish off this game so we shove
a 23 me too and I'm really grateful to
my opponent at he allowed me to use chat
mates because nowadays he'll resign here
boo so what and i've seen he always
allowed champagne this is that all
checkmate the USS experience that in my
three years yes it's rare it's very rare
because hi the tournament i played never
loved me that there was no sign of four
five moves before me so I mean one moose
oh yeah clean diesel check check educate
a champion and yes amazing I really like
I'm not remember during a check made
last line year it might have been a
while right well feed a master kumar as
oddly as it was we had him on our list
as having a rating identical to yours so
even though he doesn't have the IM title
yet even to be on par with the grand
master at least in that mathematical
capacity is a special thing he was
saying 2200 life to raising mystical
2200 but because usually scare factor 40
he jumps he won't like 200i 60 points in
school is reading this because k factor
hello k factor well so the trifecta is
complete right now let's you know
there's more to come though and no more
to game days so how do you feel about
that oh oh yeah that's true my single
days are coming oh yeah i'm really happy
in a very exhausting for me because the
competition is super strong like I think
the average is like 24 70 + 2 + 3 4 75
or some riders which might be the
strongest reemployment i ever played
like free so you should be like I'd say
the children toys are playing 400 words
but he was everyone's very strong like
all these kind of talented kids you know
I like I wonder and my today's opponent
and also check idols like 15 years old
and go to where I am but it's 25 30 so
but we were glad that you had a great
time here in this tournament so far more
to come yeah trying to get first place
now I think you're like three of us
because I wonder lost he was living
alone yeah by house point well at one
point now he lost very fast food wise
surprises so we all right hopefully I
want to talk to a wonder here coming up
but let's check out the Grandmaster norm
standing after seven rounds of play in
the GM section only three players can
earn a norm an excellent six and a half
points in this field will net Lynn and a
lemur on d a GM norm and oddly enough
four and a half points in this section
we'll get abrahamian and IM norm
alright and in the IM norm section i am
with feed a master Jol banawa who just
had a win over Doug Eckert one of our
local favorites Joel take us through the
game and show us your favorite part it's
I think blacks position is much easier
to play that's a problem with the three
basis if you can't coordinate all three
pieces against the Queen then it could
be really problematic for the player
with three pieces especially at this in
this game I have two points against one
on the queenside it's always a problem
because if I could win this pollen or I
could start advancing my pawn and he
can't coordinate his three pieces then
he can't stop my basketball and I think
that's what happened in the game so I
just want to add that instead of
ninety-five I think white should have
played rich f1 here I was expecting
Knight to e5 and then yesterday if he
plays Rick f1 I was calculating Bishop
to b4 and idea is if he takes and I can
just play Bishop f6 and the night is
trapped maybe it's practically stripped
e5 not really but I think at this point
i was i was very happy i thought i was
going to win this this game he really
couldn't coordinate his three pieces due
to his King safety the King safety was
was a major issue and here I it was a
really careless move I I knew that
roughly five ideas existed here but I
completely forgot brooke d 5 was just so
powerful here I can't just move my queen
for example 36 because after Queen e6
trying to attack the night in the rook
at the same time but he played 95 and
after Queen to f6 in group takes f5 he s
he has more tactics in the position so
oh man I wasn't happy after this well
the only attempt that I have is to go
after this pawn on day 2 but i wasn't
really sure if this is winning maybe
there's a good way for him to stop my
pawns but i think due to the time
pressure he wasn't able to find the best
defense originally I was expecting Ricky
to but repeat bill queen III where he
too could be worth b2 b3 ok I think I
was expecting something else for example
take a tree and now he played with be
one he I think I was expecting Ricky
took and after Queen takes b3 this might
be his best hope and then Bishop c5 the
file is still losing english is losing
just so we can create some sort of
fortress and stop that pond but my Kings
going to get activated and I'm going to
try to attack pressure on the King side
and I just want to add that if he plays
repeat through here then I can just take
the risk now this my pawn is going to be
unstoppable I complain 82 so probably
probably at this point this is this is
now lost there's a really cool pattern
and ban game where white has a bishop in
a night against the Queen he could form
some sort of fortress unfortunately for
white they're still points points around
and worst case i could sacrifice my
clean for these two pieces and then i
will make sure when i sacrifice my queen
that i'll be out positioning this the
King on h2 and so I can transform the
gaming through one king in point on you
but I I thought advancing the pawns
could only harm him maybe the best price
just to keep the night to me for
and maybe move the king and wait but I
but again i'm probably going to move my
i'm going to move my king all the way to
III and wait for the perfect moment to
sacrifice or maybe i could create more
weaknesses but there's certainly a lot
of different ways for black Twitter and
well pushing the pawns been really help
especially G for this probably the
biggest wonder if I could put my king on
that for then everything in whites
position this Colossus and if you have
the Queen you have to make sure to keep
the points on the board because the
Queen can't really win against a night
of the bishop with no fun and yeah yeah
this is our Z plus he's on the zooks
market well Joel congratulations on the
victory and you're welcome in and
absolutely this is a interesting
situation that you're in because while
technically we have you on the
leaderboard with two rounds left to go
you're in first place could get a norm
you don't need a norm tell us about your
situation well I already has a lot of
norms basically my primary goal in this
tournament is to get my feeder rating
over 2400 and yeah I was just so
fortunate to get invited here and yeah
well that 2,400 mark will get you that
IM title so best of luck to you thank
you for joining me and let's take a look
with two rounds left after seven the IM
norm standing by now in the IM section
only two players can earn a norm an
astounding six and a half points in this
section will net banawa and william and
i am norm
two more days to go the action continues
through Tuesday februari 21st follow all
of the action of the norm Invitational
at us chest champs calm